if you deteriorated according to your
own vices
and that went that got out of hand what
would that look like five years down the
road
you know everyone knows some people some
people flirt with
with alcoholism or drug abuse or
um or uh sex addiction
yes yes yes but that's right fractured
relationships
even candy whatever and then you know
you have a sense in your mind
of what you'd be like if you let
yourself go oh well i'd be sick man i'd
be under a bridge or something i'd
probably be behind like a
i don't know living behind a tim hortons
or something you know some type of place
i'm trying to make it local to you but
like some yeah i'd be living you know
i'd just be doing drugs or just
probably listening to aerosmith i'd be
outdoors i bet no real home
i'd have no feelings so for you so it's
for you it's a vision of homelessness
and
and substance abuse yeah yeah well you
gotta ask yourself
like okay think about that is that what
you want and i don't i mean
think about it imagine that right that's
what awaits you
well then you have a better thing to be
afraid of
it's like afraid as i am of
of gripping my own destiny here's the
alternative right
now you've created the now you've
created a reality of what that looks
like so now you have something to battle
against right
yes exactly right you need part of
part of being motivated is to be afraid
of the proper things
you know afraid as you might be of
success and fair enough
it's possible that you should be more
afraid of stagnation and failure
but you have to make those things real
for you before they have any power
yeah as you're talking i'm even
realizing that if i don't make the
the the lowest if i don't make the
reality of what could happen if i don't
take care of myself and if i were to
like devolve and disintegrate into my
worst
place if i don't make that a reality it
almost
lets me stay in the fog even more
because
now even the there's not even the the
end hasn't even been created
i've left it all just so vague that i
can just kind of meander around it's
like um
it it reminds me a little bit i didn't
want to quit smoking for a while because
if i quit smoking then i would have to
actually
then do something else good for myself
or i would have to then
be a non-smoker and a non-smoker might
then go for a run or he might
like you know uh then achieve a
different goal so one of the reasons i
realized for a while that i didn't quit
smoking was because
if i was real honest with myself i
wanted to always have an excuse
of why i couldn't do other stuff right
i think that's a really good that's the
kind of observation that's necessary so
you've made three observations so far
about
you know sort of nefarious dark motives
that keep you down
you said well there's the unwillingness
to take responsibility
um the the fear of the distance between
you and your ideal and then now you had
another one which is well
it isn't just quitting smoking because
that's part of the decision to be
healthier
well what does that mean well it doesn't
just mean quit smoking it implies other
things and
and those things are effortful in the
moment
right they pay off in the medium to long
term but they're effortful in the moment
and so and it it
that your ability to do that is
exactly part and parcel of that process
of pulling things out of the fog it's
like
and these are really good questions to
ask yourself it's like well what
what reasons do i have that i don't want
to admit
that are stopping me from doing those
things that i want to or know that i
should
i'm afraid of judgment mostly usually
afraid of judgment yeah
yes yes i'm afraid i'll fail uh
i'm afraid i'll realize that i'm not
good enough or i was never capable
enough in the first place
right that's a really big one right
there it's like um
i watched this simpsons episode recently
where bart had to get a c
on one class or or be held back
and he actually studied for like two
days and then he failed
and he broke down and he said well my
god this is so terrible because i was
failing before but
i wasn't trying and so i could always it
wasn't really failure
because i never tried i never tried but
this time i really tried and yet
i failed and well it turns out that
you know it works out for him in the end
but that's not the point i thought it
was a very
apropos episode because it is much
different to fail when you've gone all
in
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one